what do you think about ernest becker
and uh those guys that put
put death at the what is it the warm at
the core
which uh
as the main thing
the the main create like this
confrontation of our own mortality first
of all being understand that we're
mortal and then confronting the terror
of it the the fear of it
as the creative like trying to escape
the fear of death as the creative force
of human society it's like the reason we
do anything is because we're just
running away from our death
scared
do you find
some of that to be true first of all as
a
somebody who looks in the mirror looks
at yourself and your own as a human
being two just looking at society today
and three at this whole big s spread of
human history and all the cool stuff
we've created including the mysteries of
elusive
i wonder what life would look like in
the absence of the fear of our mortality
i wonder
how we'd interact with one another
if there was relatively little or no
fear of death i really do when it comes
to becker's work and others um if the
ancients were known for anything it was
running to death
it was the opposite in fact dying before
dying which is the immortality key by
the way it's not
point when i when i refer to this key
i'm referring to this notion that's
preserved in greek
if you die before you die
you won't die when you die
for some reason
the ancients prized
that experience and we talked about the
mystics of of sufism and kabulism and
christian mysticism
where you have this the same self
nodding this death before death the
divine nothingness right for some reason
the mystic saints visionaries and
ancient philosophers they ran to death
and the one message i wanted to try and
communicate with this book is how they
viewed life
that it can only be fully experienced
fully embodied
in the wake
of a really intense
perhaps terrifying but utterly
transformational encounter with death
so running to death not running away
from death
you